man we'll be behind the mic for the
third straight year man who's been at
the mic for ESPN since 1993 he is a good
buddy Karl rabbits how are you Ravi are
you doing good to be on with you we
should do it more than once a year
I agree but uh I'm grateful that you're
checking in and yeah it's been a while
and we miss uh we miss you were
delighted by all the success you guys
that happen out there and I'm happy to
be on with you thanks Rabi it means it
means a ton to hear you say that so
tonight tonight obviously Yelich is not
going to be in the mix tonight and
that's a that's a disappointment but
what are you looking forward to seeing
tonight sir he's an interesting star if
he will in baseball he reminds me a
little bit of Kawhi Leonard before Kawhi
Leonard was an NBA champion and an MVP
candidate he Yelich is one of those
who's who sort of underneath the
Harper's and the trout's and the judges
of the world so as much as we wanted
Christian Yelich in this because of his
homers you know you don't have Bellinger
in this thing and he's equal and we'd
like to see that tonight to me is all
about the sort of youthful movement that
we've seen in baseball the last handful
of years whether it's judge whether it's
Alex Bregman in Houston Vlad Guerrero
coming out of Toronto all these guys
Josh Bell in Pittsburgh in a lot of ways
and maybe you can relate to this while
we were doing sports enter the
three-point shooting contest when Larry
Bird was shooting in the dunk contest
when Michael Jordan was dunking were
fantastic and and they seemed to have
kind of lost a little bit of their mojo
a little bit of their energy in the case
of the homerun Derby I think it
continues to get better and better
they've changed it with the time and I
do think people while Harper put on a
show last year I think people in
baseball especially with the crowd
they're trying to appeal to the group
it's in this tonight whether it's joc
pederson from LA or a you know a Bregman
from Houston or a Belle from Pittsburgh
all those guys I think we'll use this
stage to grow their brand to appeal to
an audience one thing I hear rich all
the time from
players that are in the Derby people
like Pete Alonso when I was growing up
and that strikes me as funny as somebody
that is you are a kid but when I was a
kid I could remember watching the Derby
and watching Josh Hamilton and watching
Sosa and McGwire those types of things
and the reason they say I remember
watching when I was a kid is because the
important part of that is kids watch
this is a great opportunity for baseball
and for the participants to appeal to a
crowd that they may not otherwise appeal
to I'm really lucky to do the Little
League World Series and the beauty of
the Lilly World Series is it cuts across
all demographics the home run derby does
the same thing your kids are watching
your friends are watching their
grandparents are watching it's a
beautiful beautiful part of baseball and
this event and these guys can take
advantage of that yeah and then you know
dad's throwing to kids no you know who
are in the home run derby I mean I do
love the father-son aspect of it that
seems to happen every single year I took
my kids last year to see the homerun
Derby in person it's interesting that
you bring up you know the three-point
contest and the and the the slam dunk
contest part of the reason why the dunk
contest lost its luster is everybody
could dunk now and it does seem oh part
of the reason that the home run derby
might have lost its luster prior to what
you you pointed out so well is these
these neat changes with time and money
balls and things like that is that
everybody's hitting home runs now like
we know we kind of see home run derby
every single day in Major League
Baseball is there any sense of that
conversation around well I agree 100%
with you you know
heeling Cleveland you mentioned their
red-hot Roberto Perez has 16 homers
there supposed to be a difference
between Roberto Perez and Cody Bellinger
there supposed to be a difference
between a guy that is that is a 10 home
under and somebody that like George
Springer or Carlos Correia is supposed
to at 30 now they're all kind of in the
same group and and I do think there is a
little bit of home run derby every
single day but the difference is you go
to a baseball game like we did in London
17:13 here I do think the clock the
million dollars the bonus ball the 440
the exit velocity all those things are
are brought into like an SAT test it's
one day it's one night of a complete
grind everyone's focused that that is
the goal here the goal in a baseball
game is to win the darn game whether
it's a bunt to sacrifice fly or a home
run here this is strictly homers like
you know what you're getting and you
expect it when you go to a baseball game
you're kind of like can we do something
other than just hit four home runs and
win 72 so I think that we've been able
to in this fort and this event avoid the
abundance of carryover from home on
regular season to this night if we had
four home run derbies well we'd be dead
but you only have one there is a break
going on and again I do think because of
the time I mean this for this whole
thing tonight we'll take two hours maybe
you know two hours hmm a baseball game
takes three and you will see all sorts
of excitement energy clock winding down
that that's significant that's what
makes this or at least what makes makes
this a part of something that is special
and again I do think is your where your
kids more interested now are they did
they even talk about it like hey guys
tonight the home run derby oh yeah they
even had at the time and we've kept it
you know like a bracket you know writing
it down and and look it helps call
ravage here on the Rich Eisen show
calling the home run derby tonight at
8:00 Eastern on ESPN it helps to have
someone like Kyle schwarber who looks
like a fire hydrant with a bat you know
just cranking it out you know they it
really is just a fun to watch what is
the million dollars that folks might not
know about walk us through what that is
interesting one Major League Baseball
decided because there there was a little
bit and it's really funny this is the
three-point shooting contest and the
slam dunk contest I think Major League
Baseball felt that there was a bit of
apathy in the the homerun hitters
willingness to participate in a home run
derby for all the false narrative that
it screws up your swing and and some
guys are on teams that are trying to get
into the playoffs and we don't want to
risk any time
of injury or or fall-off in the second
half so let's float a million dollars
out there and and my concern initially
was people who are making hundreds of
millions of dollars will look petty if
all of a sudden they have a great
interest in participating in an event
where you could win a million dollars
when they have a million dollars you
know in your sock drawer that's not
going to work but what happened is is
that you clearly have have now three
guys in this event in Josh Bell in in
piet Alonso who are who are making
$500,000 Vlad Guerrero jr. you could
double your salary there's a million
dollars is a million dollars it's an
there's an appeal to it if we opened the
show and had 1 million dollars on the
desk and said that's what these guys are
playing for people would again be more
interested it's why some of these game
shows work so the idea of the million
was to entice players to do it many of
them like Pete Alonso has said I'm
donating a portion if I win two tunnels
four towers which is a Staten Island
group that helps out first responders
wounded warriors I'm sure you'll see
anybody that wins will make a
significant contribution to a particular
charity Major League Baseball does that
as well but again you're adding another
layer between the clock between the
bracket between the Moneyball and now a
million dollars everything that baseball
has done with the Players Association to
make this more appealing I think they're
smart enough to do it short of having
every player put up a million dollars
and the winner gets you know eight that
then this is a good start in that
direction call Ravich iran the Rich
Eisen show you mentioned how some of the
participants are talking about when I
was a kid watching it growing off let's
hit the Wayback Machine cuz I know you
were there it's been 20 years I
mentioned this earlier on the show 20
years now since the famed McGwire Sosa
Field of Dreams Pedro Martinez five
strikeouts in the first two innings
all-star game home run derby in Fenway
Park 20 years and I know I interviewed
McGwire and Sosa for baseball tonight I
do believe I took it from you and threw
it back to you you were you were at
Fenway Park let me see if I can totally
hit the Wayback Machine
you were in right field right did they
put you on top of the bleachers in right
field in Fenway Park
that day I was well what I remember
about 99 is interviewing Pedro Martinez
I think radio kind of tapped on me and
I'd interviewed Pedro Martinez when he
came out of the game and he had such a
huge bag of ice on his shoulder after
striking out five of those six Hall of
Fame guys and and that was in a lot of
ways that was the end of Pedro that
chapter he was he was great after that
but never the same never was able to
kind of recreate the 99 with the
changeup and the curveball but yeah as
much as the McGwire Sosa show was there
and Griffey was there it was it was what
happened in that game and the Ted
Williams the Tony Gwynn and the ax smell
you know do you smell your bat after you
get a foul ball that was as memorable at
night as I've experienced in baseball
and have done baseball since 95 at ESPN
yeah you're right I don't remember
during the Derby where I was my sense is
baseball tonight was you in right field
we were of that you're right you are
there you were there and I remember I
was interviewing both those guys McGwire
and Sosa before you know before the
Derby and it was the year after that 98
season that was so magical that some of
the people Pegg as the savior of
baseball you know from from from the
strike a few years before that you know
Ripken kind of helped put things back
together when he when he went around the
you know the making the lap around
Camden Yards breaking Gehrig's record in
1996 you know in 95 but you know that 98
99 was part you know I know that there's
asterisks with it now I have nothing but
the warm and fuzzy memories of that
night that was maybe the most special
thing I did at ESPN in the seven years I
was there Carl I mean my folks were
there because I grew up in that area so
my folks were there to witness it the
video of the fans and this was well
before there were seats on the
left-field wall there were there was a
screen there and they were hitting over
the screen and the fans would would
chase the baseballs now and and and this
is hardly a
reflection of me but you're absolutely
right and a lot of people have suggested
that the home run race baseball tonight
because that was before all of the all
of the RS ends were around panel Ripken
that there were certain factors that
helped resuscitate the game the program
was must-see TV like SportsCenter was
because you wanted to see and there was
no other way to find out if McGwire or
Sosa homered that night it became
something you could update immediately
you could go to the at-bat live and
you're absolutely right but that was
that was a turning point for a game that
was really struggling and to this day
I'm sure you hear it people will tell
you I gave up on it I stopped watching
it I didn't go anymore
and I think to your point to bring it
full circle an event like tonight with
the enthusiasm of a Ronald vicuna from
Atlanta which we've seen all summer long
with Pete Alonzo Todd Frazier nicknamed
the polar bear who is simple-minded on a
baseball field as he is smart off it but
said what do you anticipate doing who
said hitting more home runs than anyone
else like sometimes the most simple
things makes the most sense that these
guys will be able to continue to sort of
burn the Ember of of young fan and and
we we create that energy and it happens
one night and look we all know how
dependent we are on the weather it's a
beautiful day and night in Cleveland and
Derby Festival that's great that's great
Rabi hey great job on the College World
Series I watched the College World
Series than ever before and it was it
was really it was really a fun watch you
and the rest of the crew were great it's
a great team and by the way the great
part about the College World Series this
year was when you just looked at it
assuming you had the sound down which is
how a lot of people would prefer to
watch a game that I'm doing but this
would be the diversity of the Michigan
and Vanderbilt teams and Kumar rocker
and the players for Michigan
unfortunately you know their superstar
leadoff hitter got hurt but boy it
looked so good and it's so promising
for Major League Baseball to see these
major college programs dipping into
cities like Chicago and Detroit an LA to
find talents and turn them into baseball
players it was great yeah and it was it
was a fun watch hey before I let you go
I don't know how deep into social media
you are Instagram or not I don't think
you're on Instagram Carl
no but have you need to take a second
and check out Kilburn's Instagram feed
somebody it's a good point somebody
brought him up recently I saw something
he did maybe it was Instagram where he
was sort of it felt like I'm watching
him do a lead-in to a Rangers highlight
it has nothing to do with seemingly
anything but anticipating I saw
something and I was yes I think i
retweeted it I think it was on Twitter
and I said my guy my man he's back Carl
I mean I love it there's no you know I
mean he's usually got a martini in his
hand
and I don't know who's shooting it I
don't know I don't know what sedative
because they're definitely there's
dissolves because as you know he always
like to dissolve and I mean there's it's
it's twinkles in his eye I mean it
really mentioned not that or our Vitas
or anything like that not yet did you do
was he the guy you did most of your
sports and who did you know according to
him I mean you of course know Steve
Anderson who was running sports center
at the time about two weeks into the
Killa born ravaged Late Show after
Oberyn and Patrick I went into Steve
Anderson's office closed the door and I
said what is this about this is this is
a disaster I mean we're burning down
SportsCenter and he to his to his credit
Oh be patient but let's let's just see
where this goes and obviously as you
know you know he became wildly popular
and I was just I was just Felix to the
Oscar I was straight
and worked out really well for me well
just take just just do yourself a favor
if you're on it I will if you just want
to hop on somebody else's and just look
through it
I mean you will spend a good 15 20
minutes going through all the most
recent videos and just saying that is
that's kill that's kill be killer
whatever you want to say killer be the
pride of Montana hi Robbie
you bet always call ravish Ravich ESPN
on Twitter and check him out tonight on
the homerun Derby on ESPN at 8:00
Eastern for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app